[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL MCREYNOLDS: Hey, everybody.
Thanks for joining us for
one of the late sessions
and sticking it out
till the end of the day.
I will call out that
there's one more session
after this on Gmail
add-ons, also an Apps Script
related product.
You guys should check
it out if you really
want to go big tonight on Next.
But we're going to talk
now about Apps Script
and a new monitoring
capability that's
been made possible
with our integration
with Stackdriver Logging.
That's currently in an
early access program,
and is planned for launch to
G Suite business customers,
and possibly more
broadly down the line.
And with me here is
Romain, from Revevol,
and he's going to be covering
most of the presentation.
He is truly the expert on this,
one of our earliest adopters,
and has figured out how to hook
it up to several other cloud
technologies to extract the
maximum value from Stackdriver
Logging.
So I'll just give
a quick overview
of what we're
going to talk about
and what the technology
is, and then I'll
hand it over to Romain.
So first we're
just going to talk
about Stackdriver
Logging in Apps Script,
and how the integration works.
Romain will give an example
based on Yet Another Mail
Merge, which is a product
that he has built and manages.
And we're going
to talk about how
you get your logs from
Stackdriver into BigQuery
for analysis, and do a lot
more powerful stuff with them.
And then another example--
a Firebase example-- and
then finally Data Studio.
So Romain has really
done our work for us
in identifying all
of the ways that you
can leverage this data once
you get it in to Stackdriver.
So the basics are that we now
define console dot star methods
--
the familiar logging methods
from the JavaScript client
in the browser--
and messages-- and I should
also say objects and values
of other types that
you log to console, get
sent to Stackdriver Logging.
You can also configure Apps
Script to log exceptions
to Stackdriver Logging.
This is particularly
powerful if you're
building an add-on or something
that has a large user base.
You want to keep
track of whether it's
working for people
other than yourself,
in environments
other than your own.
And the existing
logging solution
is frankly not up to snuff.
It captures the most
recent set of logs.
And so when you're working
with a large user base,
you really need
something richer.
And so here in
project properties
you can check the
exceptions box,
and you're off and running.
Here in the view menu
there's a new menu item
for people participating
in the EAP,
or when the feature rolls out,
to view your console logs.
And here you see logs in the
Stackdriver Logging interface--
a couple of hints
at other cool stuff
you can do, creating
metrics and exports.
And then you can also filter
by either the metadata
that we send along with the
message, or the message itself
if you're sending adjacent
object as your log message.
We also, automatically,
in addition
to some other metadata,
we automatically
tag every log entry
with a user key.
And this is done
for two purposes.
Firstly, it just makes it
easy for you to see what's
happening to a particular user.
The other reason that
we do this is as kind
of a serving suggestion.
These keys are--
don't contain PII,
they're based on
the user's identity,
and they rotate once a month.
And so this is kind of extending
a Google practice to you
to use if you like, to track
users for short periods of time
and make sure the application
is working for them,
but to protect their privacy by
not tracking them over a really
long period of time.
You can log other keys--
you can log the user's email
address, for example.
Your script has access to it.
And so this is
something that you
would use for support
and triaging issues,
and it's a great way to
do that in a way that
protects your users' privacy.
And I'll hand it off to Romain
for the rest of the show.
ROMAIN VIALARD: Thank you, Paul.
OK, so-- I'm going to
present how I will--
how I have started
to use Stackdriver
Logging with my add-on,
Yet Another Mail Merge.
So Yet Another Mail
Merge is an add-on
for Google sheets, a
self sufficient add-on,
meaning that it doesn't
connect to any other service.
It really lives
only as an add-on.
It's a mail merge
add-on, so it lets
you send email campaigns using
Gmail and Google Spreadsheets.
It's one of the top add-ons
for Google Spreadsheets.
So this means that we are
now at 700,000 installations.
So 700,000 people have Yet
Another Mail Merge installed
on their Gmail Google account.
But we do have a great number
of monthly active users, more
than 80,000 monthly users,
sending email campaign
with Yet Another Mail
Merge every month,
for a total of more than 40
million emails sent monthly.
And all of that
means that we do have
to provide support to a lot
of people using this tool,
even if it's quite
simple to use.
Many people still need help
or still have issues with it.
This logging tool, like
Stackdriver Logging,
is really helpful
to investigate--
better understand--
all of the steps a user went
through before he had an issue.
So I will demonstrate
how we're using
that now to help in our
support and in other part
of the development
of the add-on.
So first, just to present
a bit, Yet Another Mail
Merge-- so it's
quite simple to use.
You simply start--
so it's a tool
to create a mail merge
campaign, email campaign, so
to send the same email to a
bunch of different people.
You start by creating
a draft in Gmail,
where you will be able to
place some place holders that
will be replaced by data
from your spreadsheet.
So, for example, here
we have a place holder
for first name here
and in the spreadsheet,
you can see that in the
first column, column A,
there's a column
named First Name.
So for each row of
the spreadsheet, Yet
Another Mail Merge
will send an email
and will reuse our
template, the email draft,
and replace in
these draft markers
by the data from
the spreadsheet.
So to install Yet Another
Mail Merge in a spreadsheet,
you just have to go
to the add-on store.
So if you had the menu
add-ons, get add-ons,
and you will see Yet Another
Mail Merge pretty easily.
It's, as I said, one
of the top add-ons,
usually it's even with
the top six add-ons
that you can find directly
when launching the gallery.
After that, so, add-ons are
[INAUDIBLE] a specific menu
in each spreadsheets, and
for Yet Another Mail Merge,
you have several menus to--
to trigger the add-on functions.
So you can either directly start
the merge if you already have
a spreadsheet containing
contacts-- recipients--
or, you can use one of our
integration to import contacts,
either from Google Contacts or
from cell phones, and so on.
So check with the--
configure from submission --
while different--
other features.
So you-- you indicate
everything you want--
mostly you select the
draft you want to reuse
to send your email campaigns.
So we list all drafts
from your Gmail account.
And then you can,
for example, set
if you want to track emails
opened, clicked, [? burned, ?]
and so on.
If you want to set
up a specific areas,
add some personalized
attachments,
and many other options that
we added over the years
for the add-on.
And once you've sent your
campaign into spreadsheets
directly, you are able to see
the results of your campaign
in real time.
So the add-on displays
information in a little sidebar
and also updates [? metrics ?]
that you scored on, letting you
know--
so how many people have
either opened, or clicked,
on your email.
OK, so, that's the--
that was just an introduction
to explain how the--
what Yet Another
Mail Merge does.
As we have a lot of
users, we thought
it was interesting to
track usage and learn how
people are using our add-on.
And for that, since
more than a year now,
we are heavily using
Google Analytics because it
lets us see the exact number
of users using the add-on
every month, day, and so
on, and to track the usage
of different features.
So before going to the
Stackdriver Logging part,
I want to show what we were
using before Stackdriver,
and when we decided
to switch and--
what decided us to switch some
parts from Google Analytics
to Stackdriver.
So in Google Analytics
you are able to easily see
you're active users, the
number of daily active users,
seven day active users,
or monthly active users.
You are able to compare over
time those users, so you
are able to see if
the number of users
is increasing from
month to month.
So if you are on a gross--
or if there are some issues
because less and less people
are using your add-on.
We are also able to
track several events.
So, for example, as
Yet Another Mail Merge
is a mail merge tool to
send email campaigns,
we are sending to
analytics information
about those e-mail campaigns.
So we are able to see how
many email campaigns were sent
over a specific period of time,
how many e-mails were sent
per campaign, and as a total.
And we can also send a lot more
information to Google Analytics
to get information about which
features people are using,
and so on.
So, for example, I
presented earlier
that, in your Gmail draft, you
can put placeholder makers so
that the email
won't look exactly
the same for every user, but
will be a bit personalized.
But not everybody is using it.
In fact, yes, more
than 36% of all users
are sending the exact
same message to everybody.
And I don't have
that on the slides,
but that's something we
have actually improved.
So there were a
lot more people not
using any kind of
personalization before,
and because we track
this kind of information,
we were able to better
indicate to people how
to personalize their e-mails.
And once they knew
that that was possible,
they used that feature--
so the ratio has
increased in favor
of more people are using
placeholders as time goes by.
It's the same for our
email tracking feature.
Now pretty much
everyone is using it,
and before it was not the case.
Thanks to all the data
we are collecting,
we were able to see where we
needed to make improvements
to be sure that people know
that the feature existed,
and that it was useful for them.
And we're tracking
several data like that,
mostly thanks to the ability
to create custom dimension
in Google Analytics that lets
you send specific data related
to your app-- your add-on--
to analytics.
So if people have activated
one feature in your app,
also to categorize people.
So, is it mostly used
by gmail.com users?
By G Suite users?
How many people are using, and
also paying, for the product?
It's a premium
product so some people
are using it and sending emails
for free, and some are paying.
What is the
proportion, and so on.
So, all that were very
interesting metric--
interesting metrics for us.
And we improve our usage of
Google Analytics over time.
And so we were also using Google
Analytics to track errors.
So that was good because
we were able to see, thanks
to all the chats and default
reportings available in Google
Analytics, directly the number
of times a specific error
happened, the number
of users impacted.
And so we were able
to know on which error
we needed to be proactive
and find a fix quickly.
But, apart from that,
sending errors to analytics
is a bit restrictive,
because you can only
send a simple string
of errors, and you
don't have all the
stack of the error,
and it's not really great to
investigate and understand
why this error is happening.
So that's why it would be better
to activate cloud logging,
and that's what we did.
We activated in Yet Another
Mail Merge the connection
with Stackdriver.
And now we are able to see,
in real time, all the errors
happening on the add-on.
So every time someone
is using the add-on
and is generating an error, we
can see the log in real time,
and we can click
on a specific log
to have all the
information about the log.
So for which user is
impacted, on which function,
at which specific line
of code in the script,
and so on and so on.
All those information are really
helpful to investigate and find
a solution.
So the question was, was
it interesting for us
to switch to
Stackdriver Logging,
knowing that we already
have a lot of stuff
in place with Google Analytics?
Was it-- in fact, does it
make sense to totally forget
about Google Analytics
and go all Stackdriver,
or should we use both of them?
And we're trying to
answer that question.
So all the advantages
of Stackdriver
is that it's, well, it's easier
to see all errors leading
to a specific user.
In Google Analytics, you must
[? have ?] aggregated data,
but it's difficult to
see precisely what is
happening for a specific user.
With Stackdriver we can
enter a specific user key,
link to a user, and
we can see everything
that's happening for
the specific user.
Plus, we do have
all the stack traces
to have all the details
about the error.
And it's really easy to use.
In fact, we don't
have-- we only have
to check a box in the
app script editor,
and all the errors start
flowing into Stackdriver.
And also, the logs are
available in real time.
So that has been very
helpful in the recent weeks
when we deployed a new
version of the add-on
because it's not always possible
to launch perfect updates.
And if you see new
errors, you are
able to quickly react and
updates and push a new version.
The limitation that we saw
with Stackdriver Logging
is mostly that there's no
real metric capability.
So this means that it's
not easy, or not possible,
to directly, from
Stackdriver Logging UI,
see the number of people
impacted by a specific error,
or see the top triggering
errors on your script and so on.
The good news is that it's
possible to export logs
to BigQuery.
And when you do that, it
solves the previous limitation
because we can aggregate the
data available in Stackdriver
Logging in BigQuery
in any way we want.
And that's what I
will show you now.
So it's very easy
to set up export
to BigQuery in
the cloud console.
You only have to click on a
few buttons to set that up.
And once that is
set up, the logs
are sent to BigQuery in real
time using streaming inserts.
A new table is
created every day.
You don't have to create the
table schema, or anything.
And it's good because
you can decide
if you want to keep
all the logs forever,
or you can set up expiration
dates on the tables
to be sure that you
won't be invoiced
too much at the end of the
month because BigQuery has
a free tier, but
if you are storing
too much data in BigQuery,
it's going to cost you
something at some point.
So usually those
kinds of logs are
useful for a few days or
months, or something like that.
And it's possible
to say to BigQuery,
"OK, I only want to keep
this data for a month,
and that's all."
Also, directly in
Stackdriver, if you
are using the free
version of Stackdriver,
logs are only kept
for seven days.
So if you want to increase that,
using the BigQuery integration
does help, because you can save
all logs forever if you want.
So once the data
are in BigQuery,
you can make
inquiries, as I said.
So the logs are split
in daily tables,
but it's easy to
perform inquiries
over multiple daily table
within a day trench.
So it means that you don't have
to look at the errors per day,
but you can look at the
errors over a period of days.
So, for example, among
the useful queries,
I will explain a bit right
after how we write our queries.
But among the useful queries
we have you can, for example,
see the number of
errors happening
every day and the number
of impacted users.
So that's just basic statistics,
but it doesn't tell you
where it's happening exactly.
So you can also list the most
recurring errors on the script,
and also look at the
number of impacted users
for those errors.
So you will know which--
which error to fix, while
some of-- most of those errors
are errors happening
on Google Sites.
And it's just a matter of adding
more retrial when it fails.
It lets you quickly see
if there's something
you can fix to improve the app.
You can see, also, the number
of errors per function name.
So to see, also, if a specific
function contains more issues
than others, and to
which part of your code
you should take care most,
based on all those data.
And we are also able to
see the number of errors
generated by each user.
As Paul explained
previously, when
Apps Script is automatically
sending data to Stackdriver,
each time it's sending
a new error log,
it provides the user
key for specific users.
So we're able to see if some
users are encountering way
more errors than other people,
and then investigate on
that because sometimes people
do have a lot of errors,
but aren't reporting
an issue to us.
So it's useful to understand
what is happening.
And maybe that's
something we can
fix because we are simply not
thinking about the specific use
case.
And so this will help
us investigate and see
that people are using the
add-on in a specific way
that we haven't
thought of, and we can
apply a fix to make it work.
OK, so, if we take a look
at the query syntax--
so first, when you want to
make a query in BigQuery,
you have to indicate the
source data to be queried.
So usually it begins with the
ID of the project on the cloud
console.
Every Apps Script project
is linked to a cloud console
project where you can
find the Stackdriver logs.
So for-- in the case of
Yet Another Mail Merge,
we have the YAMM.app_scripts
console logs that are
automatically created
when we have activated
the synchronization between
Stackdriver and BigQuery.
Here we can indicate
with BigQuery
that we want to query
multiple daily table
over a specific date range.
So after that, I
will simply tell
that I want to query the tables
from now to the last seven days
to have all the
most fresh errors.
I can do my Select, and indicate
if I want to display issues
by date, according to
the number of errors,
and indicate also
the users impacted.
So we can retrieve
the user key, as we
were saying before,
that is always
passed by Apps Scripts for
each log sent to the driver.
Also, we can indicate that
we want only to investigate
on errors, knowing
that Stackdriver
lets you log errors, but
also other information.
And we will see that very soon.
We can also do a group by to--
group by to get a date
and get some aggregates.
OK, so, exports to BigQuery
are a very nice addition.
It's not available
in Google Analytics.
So Google Analytics only
provides sample data,
and sometimes it's not enough.
If you want an integration
between Google Analytics
and BigQuery, you
have to go to--
you have to pay for Google
Analytics Premium, which
is very, very expensive.
And so, the ability
to use Stackdriver,
with it's free integration,
with BigQuery is quite useful.
So we decided that, as Google
Analytics do provide charts
and a lot of metrics
right out of the box,
it makes sense to continue
to use Analytics to track
our number of monthly
users, the usage of values
feature in the add-on,
but it made total sense
to stop plugging errors
in Google Analytics
and start logging
them in Stackdriver.
OK, and now we
will see how we can
send more logs to Stackdriver,
in addition to errors,
to help you when you want to
push updates, or understand how
people are using the add-on.
So first I will
do a little demo,
just because we
haven't showed yet
how easy it is to integrate
Apps Script and Stackdriver.
So, as we said
before, for now it's
only available as
part of EAP slash
trusted desktop program,
so you don't have it yet.
But it's rather easy to add
a new line to log information
in Apps Script.
Here, I will just send a little
information to cloud logging.
So if I run this function,
it logs automatically
this information in
Stackdriver Logging,
and I can then click on
the view console logs.
And, as it's the first time-- as
it's a new Apps Script project,
I haven't actually
enabled logging before.
So Apps Script is
asking me if I want
to enable exception logging
for all future execution
of the script.
And that's very
useful because this
means that without adding
any more lines of code,
every time the script
produces an error,
it will be automatically sent to
cloud-- to Stackdriver Logging.
So here it lets me open
the console project linked
to my Apps Script protect--
opens directly in
this console project--
my [? in this cloud ?]
project Stackdriver Logging,
and I can see the
information I just sent.
Where is the timestamp, my
user key for this project,
so if multiple users
are using the script,
they will of their own user key.
I can see that the--
it has-- the log has been
sent by the function name
my function, that the
[? invocation ?] type is
editor, and you--
it's also makes a difference
if logs are coming from--
time drive and trigger--
from a UI of your add-on in the
spreadsheet-- in the sidebar--
and so on.
So it's quite useful
to exactly see
how the error happened exactly.
And so here it's not an
error, it's a simple log.
If I want to generate an
error, it's very simple.
So here, for example,
a mistake in the code.
I don't-- I haven't put that
console.log but console.org.
And so If I start
streaming the log,
I should be able
to find the errors.
You can see that here I haven't
entered any new line of code,
not to try [? catch, ?]
or anything, to send
the error back to Stackdriver.
It's just that among
the project properties,
log exceptions is checked
now, automatically.
It means that every time the
script will show an error,
I will be able to find
the error in Stackdriver.
That's very useful
because you don't
have to add any
complexity to your code,
and you can benefit from
the feature right away.
That's all for the demo.
If I can go back to
the presentation,
thank you very much.
So in addition to
basic information
like the [? error ?]
I just entered,
it's also possible to
send additional info
as JSON objects.
So, for example, here we
are collecting information
about the number of e-mails
sent to better understand
if people are able to send
all their emails in one batch,
or if they have to do it in
multiple batches, and so on.
So you can put a lot of
different information--
and you will retrieve all this
information in Stackdriver
Logging as JSON output.
And you can then reuse all that
information to filter the logs.
So if you see at the
top of the screen shots,
there's a little
query bar where you
can indicate that you want
to filter the data based
on the JSON payload and the
data in the JSON payload.
So that's really
useful, especially
when you are unloading
the support for the app
because if you need to see
everything that happened
to a specific user who
is asking for help, well,
we can easily add
information using--
or consult that log at
every important point
during the use of the add-on.
And so, for example,
I can automatically
collect the remaining
daily quota,
and doing that I don't
send the email myself.
I'm calling the Gmail
API to send emails
that each user has a specific
quota to send emails every day.
So I can check the
quota beforehand,
and see how many emails he
will-- he was able to send,
and the time needed to send
all those emails, the remaining
quota after that,
and so on and so on.
And with all those
information, when
someone asks for help
on our support platform,
we're able to check back
the logs for these users,
and this is really
helpful to understand
what he has done because
every user is not
able to exactly describe what
he has done before having
a specific issue, and we are
able to see all the history
and better help him
understand what went wrong.
Something-- we started using
Stackdriver Logging in part
because--
due to a change
in the Gmail EPI--
a lot of users reported
that it took time
to send email campaigns.
And so we wanted to know
exactly how many people
were impacted by slow sending
time for our email campaign.
So we started to
tracking that exactly--
to track that exactly.
We added different
information to understand
what could cause this issue.
Could it be equally
different of the draft size?
So, for example, if you change
a lot of images and attachments
to your draft, so you end
up with a 20 megabyte draft
that you will send
to 1,000 people,
it means that you will, in
fact, send 20 gigabytes of data
with your campaign.
And so that might explain why
some people find it a bit slow.
So in fact, it was
not the reason,
and we were able to see that
it really simply depends
on the number of emails
you want to send.
Gmail-- the Gmail API--
has specific
threshold to make sure
that you are not sending
too many emails in a very
short time.
And based on all the data we
aggregated with Stackdriver,
we're able to update
all documentation
to indicate to people the time
needed to spend a campaign--
to send a campaign based
on the recipients you add.
And we were-- we were
able also to update
add-on itself to warn users
before they send a campaign.
So, for example, if they're
done with spreadsheets and want
to start a campaign sending
e-mails to more than 100 and--
1,200 users, we know that
it will take thirty minutes.
So we display a
warning, it will take
some time we have to leave your
computers open for some time,
so do you want to
do it now or do
you want to reschedule
your campaign, and so on.
OK.
We've displayed previously the--
always the user
keys, so Apps Script
generates a specific
user key for each user
and then sends it to
Stackdriver Logging.
But in fact, if a user sends
you a [? ship ?] request,
you have to match this
user and his email address
with a specific user key.
And so in Yet
Another Mail Merge we
are using Firebase as
our database, where
we are storing user profiles.
In each user profile we
are storing the user key,
so that when someone
asks for help
we are able to open his user
profile, get that user key,
and use that to find all logs
related to the specific user.
So to do that there's simply--
in Apps Script, you can
call [? session ?] that
get temporary active user
key, and send that information
to your own database.
So in our case, we are
sending that to Firebase.
And so that's especially
useful to investigate when
people are asking for help.
Also, as it's yet
another tool added
to add metrics and do
some analytics on usage
of the add-on, you might
want to aggregate everything
in a single dashboard.
And while the good news is that
our studio is here to help,
there have been some other
session about that studio,
so I won't speak more
about it-- just that it
is possible to build a single
dashboard where you will
aggregate information
from Google Analytics,
and information
from Stackdriver,
so you have everything
in one single place.
And it's not pretty,
but you can actually
do a very pretty dashboard
with that studio.
OK, so, some resources.
So if you want to have access
to Stackdriver Logging,
for now you have
to join the EAP.
So you have
[INAUDIBLE] for that.
There's also a
documentation explaining
how to activate Stackdriver
Logging on your script
and how to use it, especially
the console.log part,
and everything outside of
the basic error logging.
There are documentation
also on how to export
Stackdriver logs to BigQuery--
so how to set the
synchronization up,
and also the query
reference, to know
better how to query multiple
table over a [INAUDIBLE]
and other things like that.
At the beginning of
the presentation,
I also spoke about
Google Analytics.
If you also want to start
using Google Analytics
in your add-ons, know that
there are some specificities,
and so there is a blog post
available on the Google
Developer blog about that,
about how to best use the user
IDs and a lot of other
features in Google Analytics
for indicates of
Apps Script add-ons.
And if you're interested
in using Firebase
as your database for your add-on
or any Apps Script project,
there's a code library and
some examples that are also
available at this address.
PAUL MCREYNOLDS: Awesome.
Thank you, Romain,
that was great.
Thanks everybody for
coming late in the day.
It was great to see you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]